uh sort of chatterjee telling us about
uh quark confinement i don't know what
level your talk will be at so let me
just advertise on your behalf that
actually uh so has written a great uh
sort of uh survey about such things
and actually uh has lecture notes from a
course
i don't know forget to get now when you
taught it but they're quite uh nice
lecture notes on
like an introduction to quantum field
theory for for mathematicians
uh so yeah so if if if your interest is
piqued
uh there are some good resources to look
at uh so without further ado yeah
okay thanks thanks james uh okay thanks
uh for the invitation to the organizers
and uh
you know unfortunately i'm teaching two
classes this quarter and you know it's
just
taking up all my time so i just took a
break from teaching to give this lecture
it's just in the slot when i have no
no teaching um so um
okay so let me get into it right away um
a quantum
gauge theory is also known as this
quantum yang mills theories are
components of the standard model of
quantum mechanics so that's
the best predictive model of the quantum
universe as of now
um and uh so unfor the unfortunate thing
is that um
you know there has been a lot of
research on this to construct quantum
gauge there is a context of quantum
yield meals theories
and uh physically relevant theories have
not yet been constructed the ones that
actually apply to real particles
uh have not yet been constructed so
there have been some constructions you
know these five-four theories in three
dimensions you know there are some
constructions but
um but the ones that are really
important for uh for for physics i have
not even been constructed
um so the most popular approach to
solving this uh
this question is by this program of
constructive field theory which
was very active in the 60s and 70s and
80s and
then still it's uh you know it's active
um so in this approach what one starts
with is the
statistical mechanics model on the
lattice
and then um next step is to pass to a
continuum limit of this model so
you know in probability we all know what
that could potentially mean you know
pass to continue limit of this model
a third step is to show that this
continuum limit satisfies certain axioms
uh you know it's called actions it i
mean it's basically properties a bunch
of properties they have to satisfy
um such as reflection positivity and a
whole bunch of other things
so there are various different sets of
axioms and
um if any one of these set of actions is
satisfied then there is a standard
machine that allows the construction of
a quantum field to use a quantum field
theory is an operator value distribution
okay so that's the formal you know if
you if you ask somebody
what is a quantum field there is an
operative value distribution so it's
sort of
some object defined on some space where
which if you integrate over a region you
get an operator instead of a number
okay uh and so starting from a continuum
limit of this
of a of a statistical mechanics model
which is typically you know a
regular you know distribution in the
sense of in a schwarz distribution maybe
uh from that how do you get an operative
value distribution there is a standard
machine for that
and one can do that the the most
difficult step is usually to construct
this
continuum limit of the statistical
mechanics model so so in that sense
these are
mostly these are probability questions
so that's uh the fascinating thing for
for our problem is that these are
probability questions
and so taking this program to its
completion is one of the clay millennium
problems as
uh as you know um so the statistical
mechanics models that are
uh really relevant in in physics in the
standard model are known as lattice
gauge theories
because these are the ones that are
really the ones that are
the important ones uh a lattice gauge
theory may be coupled with a higgs field
or it may be a pure lattice gauge theory
so there are additional complications if
you couple it with the higgs field
so we will not talk about that we'll
deal with only pure lattice gauge
theories in this talk um
a pure lattice gauge theory has three uh
components
one is it's a gauge group usually a
compact matrix lead group
so sometimes mathematicians use gauge
group to mean something else but
here you know it's just the group
associated with the with the theory
um it's a compact matrix lead group and
a dimension of space time
which the most important case is for and
a parameter known as the coupling
strength
okay so that's for pure lattice gauge
there isn't if you couple with the higgs
field there are some more parameters
so these theories on their own even
without passing to this limit
um can yield substantial physical
information so they're actually
you know huge super computers running
simulations for this theory so these are
statistical mechanics models so
presumably you can simulate from them
using a gibbs sampler you know something
like that
and people are doing that so there is a
and what they want is to
is to predict the masses of elementary
particles
and then in cases where the masses can
actually be measured they
they want to match those and even with
lattice gauge theories they measure
they predict and they measure and it's
you know usually 90 percent accuracy
that they
you know it's not perfect but it's 90
accuracy they can get
these numbers so there are there are big
big programs running this
uh and these things so there is this
general field called lattice qcd
which you can look up um
so so there are very you know there are
many important questions about lattice
gauge theories and two
um very important questions have
uh lattice gauge to theoretical
formulations the first is the question
of the angle's mass gap
uh so in um you know mask for a quantum
field theory means basically a gap in
the spectrum of the
of the hamiltonian considered as an
operator but
you know if we just boil down the whole
thing to lattice gauge theories what it
uh turns out to be is that mass gap is
the same as um
equivalent to exponential correlation so
so this is a
kind of subtle point this certain kind
of boundary condition so we'll come to
that later
it's usually not stated in this way
people just say mass gap means
exponential degree of correlations
okay um and uh
it's not hard to establish a
sufficiently large value of the coupling
strength which means at high temperature
so
as uh you know probably most of you know
that
uh if you have some kind of mark of
random field uh
gives um this distribution then
if if beta is small enough it's not hard
to establish
uh exponential degree of correlation
there are standard machines to do that
now the theories are physically relevant
only at week coupling so that's the
problem
okay so nothing comes for free so you
can do it at strong coupling but the
main
physical physical relevant regime is the
weak coupling
which is the large beta corresponds to a
large bit and statistical mechanics
um so it's not known how to
mathematically establish mass gap in 4d
or 3d lattice gauge theories that we
coupling
and uh but there are huge monte carlo
studies and they show we
beyond out that these are these are
correct so the people believe that
so i'll give you precise um you know
conjectures you know what what is uh
what is expected later on okay
the second question is a question of
quark confinement
uh so quarks are the constituents of
various elementary particles such as
protons and neutrons a proton is made up
of a number of quarks
and and so the quarks are never observed
freely in nature
so uh so you they never come out somehow
come out of being bound to each other so
you know quark antiquark pairs abound
so it's not clear you know why this is
the case so
so this is you know should be you know
if the standard model is correct it
should be
possible to reduce this from the
standard model but the problem is that
all
the physics that is done the theoretical
physics that is done with the standard
model is
mostly all perturbative so but to
understand quark confinement you really
have to understand
things non-perturbatively and the series
expansions that they have you know they
those things don't converge and so so
that's that's the big growth block why
quark confinement has not yet been
understood
is that you really need to understand
these lattice gauge theories in a non
nonprofit
way okay and uh so so the consensus
seems to be that
satisfactory explanation doesn't exist
although there are some explanations
um so why um so where do you start
so i'll introduce lattice gauge theory
soon uh so
what wilson uh one of the pioneers in
this area suggested that
uh core confinement is equivalent to
showing that the relevant lattice gauge
theory satisfies what's
known as wilson's area law
and a number of deep results are known
so i'll discuss those
but the main questions are all um uh are
are open okay so can i ask a high level
question
uh core confinement is what is that this
is very this is a like a physics
question but that's what's responsible
for the the the fact that the
the strong nuclear force doesn't satisfy
like an inverse
square law like yeah electricity and
gravity and so on yeah so so it is all
about the strong force so the strong
force
is the thing that uh causes this
confinement and you know why
why does that happen so that's not yeah
exactly
so so it's believed that uh the the
potential so i'll come to that so the
potential
between two quarks separated by a
distance r actually grows linearly in r
okay so that's uh you know that's why
they cannot separate beyond a certain
distance so
so the force remains constant so as the
quarks move away the force doesn't
decrease
um okay so uh so the main result
uh so i have not introduced the
mathematical model till now so i'll just
give you the broad overview and then
i'll give you the precise statement
later on
the main result is that if the gauge
group is compact connected and as a
non-trivial center
then the presence of exponential
correlations under arbitrary boundary
conditions implies
wilson's area law so in some sense you
can say that mass gap
implies confinement in some broad sense
um so the non-triviality of the center
is known as center symmetry and this is
this has been conjectured in physics for
a very long time that center symmetry
this non-trivial center is very
important
so there are you know so3 lattice gauge
if the group is so3 for instance which
has a trivial center
then it's not supposed to be confining
and this is the first result which
kind of gives the rigorous justification
for that that why it is non-trivial
center may be important
and um so so this was a
slightly confusing thing uh in the
beginning so
so this i so this is i call it strong
mass gap
this exponential decay holding under
arbitrary boundary conditions
so um so okay so let me get to that
so there's a long standing belief in in
physics uh originating in this work
work of two that mass gap plus unbroken
center symmetry implies confinement so
this is what the phases believe mass
graph plus unbroken center symmetry and
now unbroken central symmetry is not
rigorously defined so there are some
definitions in physics which are
kind of complicated so i'm not going to
that but it's not a rigorously defined
concept this unbroken sentence symmetry
now so when i when i first uh you know
circulated my paper um
uh you know the physicist uh ed whitton
and
steve schenker here so they were a
little confused because
uh you know there are some models which
are known to have mass gap
but still um don't are not supposed to
be confining
okay so what's what's going on here
uh on the other hand you know su 3 you
know theory the theory of the strong
force is supposed to have mass gap at
all beta and so
uh you know so
so what it turned turned out is that
mass gap means exponential decay
as it is commonly said but it's only
under a specific kind of boundary
condition that's dictated by the
findment path integral of the theory
and so this is you know what um uh
so finally you know uh from edward and
you know that's that's what
what he thinks so that uh uh the strong
mass gap is
this the strengthening of this condition
that it's hold under arbitrary boundary
conditions it's it's what prevents the
breaking of center symmetry okay
and okay so so there is you know okay
there is all this uh
thing about that but uh this is the this
is the precise result i mean
as precise as it can be without
presenting the model that if you have
exponential correlations under arbitrary
boundary conditions
then um the wilson's area law will hold
and that is kind of surprising because
you know uh okay so
well why is surprising i have to define
the model but um
yeah so um okay so this is uh roughly
the content of this talk and
and then i'll go into the definition
rigorous definition of the
of the is the strong mess gap a
reasonable assumption i mean in the
sense that
it's sort of expected to hold so um
the thing is you know we have very
little understanding of degree of
correlations in this model so
for example in su-3 lattice gauge theory
it is believed that exponential decay of
correlation should hold in four
dimensions should hold at all beta
okay but we don't even know how to prove
any kind of degree of correlations at
large beta later
let alone exponentially graph
correlations so so that's
that's beyond the proof and so it's not
clear whether uh you know whether the
original mass gap assumption you know
that
it was essentially look of correlation
whether that is true well that is also
an assumption
uh but you know i've heard from people
that
that is believed that at all beta you
have unique gifts
you have a unique gift state uh you know
for su 3 theory for non-abelian theories
that you have unique gibbs state
and so it is not you know it is possible
that it holds
uh you know if if exponentially k holds
then
it's possible that it holds in the
theories where it doesn't hold under all
boundary conditions but it holds under
some boundary conditions so there are
some theories known like that so those
are discrete you know z2 theory for
instance when the gauge group is
is finite finite a billion gauge group
so there are some results which say that
uh you know there there is
non-uniqueness but then there is
non-uniqueness of the gibbs state
and so if it is unique so then one can
expect so it's not clear it's not clear
but but what certainly shows is that
in the full regime where you have
exponential
correlations uh under this arbitrary
boundary conditions
so in in some sense in the full high
temperature regime
and in su 3 it's believed to extend to
the full
uh full real positive axis
um you know you you have this
you have will sense a uh area so that's
you know that's
that's all i can say about that um
so we'll see so uh so here's the
notation
uh let n and d be two integers uh
and uh let g be a closed connected
subgroup of the integral group u n
okay so just um you can be more general
than that but i'm restricting myself to
that
let b n be a large box in z d
okay let e n be the set of positively
oriented nearest neighbor edges of b
n okay so you have this large box and
you have this positively oriented edges
let omega in the set of all functions
from here into g so that is you're
attaching a group element to each
positively oriented edge
and then for a negatively oriented edge
you just define the matrix attached to
that to be the
inverse of the matrix attached to the
positively oriented edge so you just
that's that's the convention that is if
you attach a matrix to an edge e
then in the opposite orientation you
attach the matrix e uh
the inverse of that that matrix okay so
that's that's how you assign
matrices to edges okay
now a placket is a set of four directory
directed edges that form the boundary
for square
and let pn be the set of all blackets in
this large box
okay now given some plucket p
and some configuration define omega p as
follows
so you take you write the placket as a
sequence of edges like this
going in some directions e1 e2 e3 e4 and
define omega p to be the product of
these
okay so now there is some ambiguity here
about the choice of e1 which is the
first
edge in which direction will you go but
we will just need the quantity
real part of the trace of omega p and
this will not be affected by these
choices so this is fine
so you have just these uh so so you have
matrices attached to edges and from that
you get matrices attached to blackheads
okay so the plackets are always
two-dimensional uh even though
the space may be you know higher than
two dimensional
so you have these pluckets and now we
define the hamiltonian hamiltonian comes
in terms of these omega ps
okay the real part of the trace of omega
p so let del e n denote the
set of positively oriented boundary
edges and let del omega n be the
set of all assignments of matrices to
this boundary edges so that's
these are this is a set of boundary
and then you have interior edges and
then you have
assignments to interior edges so you fix
the boundary condition then you have
freedom inside okay and then what you do
is you take a boundary condition and
take
a configuration of matrices attached to
the interior edges
and extend it to the full boundary by
just defining it to be equal to the
boundary condition
outside but anyway you know this is all
just technical so this is the main thing
the hamiltonian
is is a sum over all blackets of the
real part of the trace of
of omega p so for each plucket you're
multiplying these matrices
okay and then you're taking the real
part of the trace
and taking the sum and in the sense of
uh you know i should put a minus here
but i'll not put a minus so it'll minus
and the other minus will cancel so
so the so the measure will be in the
next slide e to the
e to the beta times h okay so
so where is this real part of trace
maximize so these remember these are
unitary matrices so these omega
e's are unitary matrix so their products
are also unitary matrices
the real part of the tracer from
university matrix is maximized when
the matrix is the identity so if beta is
large
what so this hamilton this thing will be
large when the omegas are all close to
identity
okay and that is a lot of configuration
so that's not
uh you know not like in the icing model
that you just have two configurations
okay
okay so the pure lattice gauge theory on
this big box with gauge group g
coupling parameter beta boundary
condition delta is this probability
measure
sorry you know it's a lot of notation
but uh
you know just bear with me and uh
you know just you know unmute and ask if
you have a question because i cannot see
the chat messages
uh so so it's uh it's proportional
to this density times the product heart
measure okay
so again to just to repeat you have this
big box in the lattice
on each edge you have a matrix you have
a unitary matrix from some group
okay subgroup of the injury matrix so so
you have a element from that and then
for each placket which is a you know
little square of edges you multiply the
matrices along the edges
and take the real part of the trace of
that sum up over all the
all the plackets and that's your
hamiltonian so you put that e to the
beta times that in front of the product
r measure
okay and that gives you the lattice
gauge theory so that's the definition of
lattice gauge theory
pure largest gauge without a hex field
okay
right so here beta is the
coupling parameter so beta is one over g
zero squared g zero is called the
coupling strength
and then you define as usually defined
the expectation of a function with
respect to this lattice gauge theory in
the usual way the angle bracket notation
the integral of f with respect to this
this measure
and you know we are also putting a
boundary condition there
okay
any questions so far
okay so the area law let pi be a finite
dimensional unity representation of the
group
okay so you have a subgroup you have a
compact league group so
um the we can consider finite
dimensional neutral representations
and chi be the character of pi so you
take the
trace of pi applied to an element
let l be a closed loop in this box with
directed edges e1 through ek
and given a configuration omega the
wilson variable wl omega is defined as
this chi of pi this character applied to
this product
omega e1 omega e2 up to omega ek so you
are
you're looking at directed edges so you
multiply along the in the proper
direction
okay
and again since we are taking the trace
it doesn't matter which edge is chosen
to be e1 okay
so as long as the reaction is correct it
does it doesn't matter which edge is
chosen to be
e1 and the lattice gauge theory is
satisfied to
said to satisfy wilson's area law for
this representation
pi if the if it satisfies this that
uh the um you know the
the wilson loop expectation so this is
called the expected val wilson with
expectation for this
loop l the wilson loop expectation in
absolute value is bounded by c1 times e
to the minus c2 times the area enclosed
by l for
any rectangular loop so if you take a
rectangular loop just a rectangle
uh the area enclosed by that is just its
length times its breadth
but you know if you have more
complicated loops in particular in high
dimensions then
you it's it's interpreted to be the
minimum surface area enclosed by
the loop in some sense uh but i'm not
going to that so just
restrict myself to rectangle loops uh
where c1 and c2 are positive constant
that
that depend on the group the coupling
parameter the dimension and the
representation pi
but uh not on the on b n on
not under this n here because we are we
want to take eventually one again to
infinity and we have an infinite volume
measure
and this thing should hold for the
infinite volume measure also
okay so that's that's called wilson's
area law
and okay so here is where what i
mentioned some time ago that it's
surprising that
one can expect this because you know
you're multiplying these matrices along
the loop and if you have decay of
correlations
you expect that uh you know
it should be something e to the minus
the perimeter okay
because you're multiplying a number of
things which become more and more
independent as you
go far away so so why do we have the
area instead
okay which is much bigger than than the
perimeter so
uh so that's that's the mysterious thing
about aerial law
why it's i don't know how wilson
conjectured that this would be the case
but
um you know so that's the
so that's the surprising thing okay
all right so let me now go into what's
known about the
well first why does it imply confinement
so
um so just a very brief uh idea
about that so let vr be the potential
energy for static quark anti-pair
separated by distance r
and if computations from quantum field
theory
indicate that if you have a rectangular
loop of side lengths r
and t in the continuum limit of four
dimensional su three gauge theory
so su 3 is the lattice gauge theory that
corresponds to the strong force
and a suitable representation pi then
this wilson loop expectation should
behave like e to the minus v
r times t where v r is its potential so
if the area law holds then vr should
grow linearly in
r so the so the derivative of vr which
is the force
remains constant and by conservation of
energy this means that the pair will not
be able to separate beyond
a certain distance the energy that it
starts out with so it'll never be able
to separate beyond that
on on its own okay so
um so now renovation group arguments
predict that this beta has to be sent to
infinity as the lattice spacing goes to
zero when you take the continuum limit
so this is
again this is highly non-trivial and it
comes from from
normalization group that this should
happen
to take so so you you do not keep beta
fixed and take the continuum limit
you have to as you as the lattice
spacing goes to zero you also have to
take beta to infinity like
in four dimensions like the logarithm of
the lattice spacing so that's
some some actually some precise multiple
of the logarithm of the lattice spacing
uh so that's uh what is uh what is
theorized and
um and so to uh
so so in the first step to prove it in
lattice in lattice gauge theories
you have to prove it for large beta okay
so that's that's the thing that you have
to somehow prove it for large beta
you know small beta is not going to
imply confinement of quarks and there is
much stronger reason to
for that you know i'll come to that in a
couple of slides
okay
okay so so there are some basic facts so
i'll just survey very briefly survey the
results that are known about the area
law and most of these are
pretty old results in 40 years old so if
can you
is there some toy model where i would
you know
i would be able to see exponential decay
in the area
sort of yeah i'm coming to that so i'm
coming to that so
uh so okay so so it's easy to show first
of all that the areola holds at all beta
in any two-dimensional theory so
so the two-dimensional is particularly
easy because
two-dimensional lattice gauge theories
can reduce to one-dimensional problems
by a process known as gauge fixing
and as soon as you go to one dimension
you know everything becomes very
manageable uh and you can do that so
that's not that's not hard
um so that's one result uh xyler
in 1978 proved that the area of the
lower bound holds for any theory at any
bit essentially any theory of any beta
so so
area law is the best you can hope for uh
you know if you look at lattice gauge
theories on the other hand simon and efe
uh prove that a perimeter upper bounds
hold upper bound holes for any period
any beta and that
again uh you know is not so hard
especially with probabilistic arguments
uh it's not not very hard to establish
that
uh that a perimeter upper bound holds
for any theory to any data and it's
basically because
you're multiplying a large number of
unitary matrices and each of them has a
little bit of freedom
given everything else even given
everything else so this little bit of
freedom is going to accumulate
and you're going to get an exponential
decaying the perimeter okay
okay there are some deeper results so
the first is this um
well-known result of osteowater and
zeiler who showed that the area la holds
that small beta
for any theory in any dimension so given
a theory there is a small enough
threshold beta0 so that if beta is less
than beta0
then uh the area law holds for rectangle
so they proved it for rectangles that
the area law holds
and this is not an easy result you know
it uses these
expansions and then uses um quite a bit
of uh
representation theory and all that
okay so here is the very um
you know interesting thing about dlr is
that in four dimensional u1 theory
so okay so this result was you know
somewhat
disconcerting because you know u1 gauge
theory
is supposed to describe electromagnetism
which is you know theory of photons and
electrons so
so photons are certainly not bound okay
so the so there is no confinement of
photons
so it was not clear that if you know
uh you know if if um if the area
law holds that small beta for any theory
including u1 theory now how is this
possible because u1 is supposed to
describe photons
and you know this was rigorously proved
but faces realize this
soon after wilson's work that the area
law
should hold at small beta for
essentially any theory um
and so what uh alan good and frolic and
spencer they showed is that for four
dimension four dimensional u1 theory
the arlo actually breaks down at large
bit and instead of perimeter lahore so
this is known as deconfinement
transition and this is
exactly what should happen because in
four dimensional u1 theory you don't
expect
uh don't expect the area
and not not even area allow anything
worse than the perimeter law
or maybe anything better than the
perimeter cannot hold because
in a vr if if the perimeter law holds
then you know vr is essentially constant
uh the potential is constant so um so
this is called a deconfirming transition
and this was physically expected because
four dimensional theories related to
photons which are not confined
however in three dimensions it was shown
and this is also a very
deep and difficult paper that the avala
holds that all beta in three dimensional
u1 theory so unlike in four dimension
three dimension even u1 theory is
confining
and this is still the only non-trivial
case whereas
areala has an established at large beta
okay
there are some other results uh frolic
showed that confinement holds in
holes in s1 suv and theory if and only
if well if it holds
the corresponding zn theory um there are
other results which connect confinement
in d dimensional
lattice gauge theories with exponential
correlations with d minus one
dimensional non-linear sigma models
and uh then there are other examinations
of
these things in at non-zero temperature
so you can also add a different
parameter called temperature
no not beta and
to answer james's question uh there's a
toy model for exhibiting a sharp
transition from the confined to the
the confining regime was studied in this
paper of eisenman changed his folic and
russo
so there is there are some time models
which are not lattice gauge theories
which are somewhat simpler than lattice
gauge series where things are more
more manageable so there are some things
like that
um recently you know there have been
some things so this
uh you know area large at small bit of
arbitrary loops
where area is the area is a minimum
surface area this was established in
large and limit of these theories in
some papers that i wrote
and also with my student jeffrey of
um and and then
i have been trying to figure out the
exact leading order behavior of
the of the constants in the exponent so
in a very very simple
case this four dimensional z2 theory i
could do that
recently and this result was extended to
4d theories with finite billion groups
in this paper and with
general finite groups you know by my
student sky cow
in this very nice paper uh so
uh so this has been some development but
as you can see
that the question about uh
four-dimensional su-3
theory which is the most important of
lattice gauge theories
the area law is supposed to hold at all
beta but has not been proven and that's
the
that's the main thing so the main open
question is to prove the area law for
4d se3 theory at arbitrary large values
of beta
but however you know proving it for any
other four dimension on a million theory
would be would be very very interesting
okay not really a c3 theory
uh it's not supposed to hold for 48
billion theories at large beta
uh or with even non-billion theories
with finite grade groups unfortunately
so
even if you have finite gauge groups so
it you have to have a four-dimensional
uh you know you have to have a theory
with the gauge group which is
uh both non-abelian and uh you know it's
basically
it has to be a compact leak group so
that's that's what it has to be
okay so now let me come to the main
result that i'm going to state
uh so here is the center symmetry
assumption so assume that the center of
g is non-trivial
and there is uh in the sense that uh i
is not trivial and there is an element
g0 in the center so that this
representation pi applied to g zero is
also non-trivial that c times that entry
where c is not equal to one so c has to
be a complex number of modulus one but
it's not equal to one so there is a
non-triviality of the center
and the strong mass gap assumption
precisely says the following so say that
two edges are neighbors if they both
belong to some common placket
and say that a measurable map f from
this space of configurations we realize
the local function supported an edge if
the value of the function depends only
on the values of the matrices
that are neighbors of supported edges
that are neighbors of
a given edge and so let's say you have
two local functions like this and the
distance between them is defined as a
distance euclidean distance between the
midpoints of the supporting edges so
some definition of distance
so then the assumption is that there are
positive constants k1 and k2 depending
only on the gauge group
the coupling parameter and the dimension
and not on the size of the box that
you're taking or the boundary condition
such that for any local functions the
correlation the truncated correlation
is bounded by k1 times e to the minus k2
times the distance between
the two functions you know the supports
of the two functions
okay so that's the strong mass gap
assumption that i'm making and
and let me just tell you this is true if
beta is small enough
that is not hard to show that this is
true if beta is small enough
okay so that's one situation but but
then i'm not assuming beta is small i'm
just assuming that this
decay condition holds okay
and so then the theorem is that uh let g
be a compact connected
subgroup of u n for sum n and let pi be
a finite dimensional unity
representation of g
take any dimension d and any beta and
consider the lattice gauge theory on
this
large cube bn suppose that the central
symmetry and strong strong mass gap
assumptions are satisfied
so then there are positive constants so
that
well any loop that's sufficiently away
from the boundary
uh the wilson's area noise any
rectangular loop um
the the wilson's area law is satisfied
uh
and moreover there is a unique infinite
volume give state you can reduce from
these conditions the strong mass gap
condition
uh and um this bound holds for any
rectangular lip
a loop l if the expectation on the left
is taken respect to this infinite volume
so you you know this is
slightly messier if you state it in a
finite box so you can for
aesthetic reasons you can just go to the
infinite volume and you can show this
unique infinite volume keep state and
and this this this holds
okay so that's the main statement
any questions
okay so this this says that uh
you know from exponentially curved
correlations this particular version of
exponential correlations
you can you can deduce the area law just
and the argument is fully probabilistic
so it doesn't involve um the
representation theory or
uh or other other ingredients the fully
probabilistic argument
okay so some remarks um this this mass
strong mass gap is stronger than usual
mass gap because uh the usual mass gap
means exponentially kind of a specific
kind of boundary condition
uh and this will satisfy the strong
mascot assumption satisfied by any
lattice gauge theory if there is small
enough so this
uh this so that's the result that i
showed implies this old result of foster
water and sciler
but it says more um and
uh so it is not clear you know coming
back to james's question that strong
mascot assumption holds that all beta in
four
dimensional than a billion theories as
conjectured for usual mascot but it's
not
impossible and uh and if this is proof
that will solve the confinement problem
and
well if this is proved to be wrong that
would be very interesting too you know
if you have
you know uh if you have a phase
transition because we have no
information about any kind of phase
transition in
non-abelian four-dimensional theories so
um
so if this is not true then there will
be it will have some kind of phase
transition
at least a costly stylus transition okay
and that would be extremely interesting
too
and so this is the first rigorous result
that throws light on this role of
roles of mass gap and central symmetry
and confinement so these are well
established in the physics discourse so
they
they say that this although you know
there is actually no
completely accepted argument about uh
confinement
uh but they you know all these
heuristics um
i mean even in the physics sense uh not
yeah and uh and so
uh so there are these heuristics which
say that if you have mass gap and
unbroken center symmetry then you'll
have confinement so this
is uh sort of the first result that
gives
some kind of rigorous justification of
that okay
okay so let me go into the proof sketch
uh how do you how do you prove uh okay
so it's really hard
in in a uh
in a zoom talk but let me try is center
symmetry
some kind of coercivity condition and
so can you can you say a bit more about
that i
yeah so there's something in the group
that's attractive in some sense i mean
in terms of phase i mean i just
the exponential decay makes sense the
center of symmetry i'm is
i have no intuition yeah so it comes
from the proof somehow so i have no
intuition either so i'll show you the
step in the proof where
where center symmetry is used and they
think that without center symmetry like
as i said so3
lattice gauge theory even in four
dimensions so3 lattice gauge theory is
supposed to
not be confining at large beta that's
what they say
and because it has a trivial center and
and so i i don't know so um so let's see
in the proof so we'll see where it comes
from
so you have this rd dimension and the
let the first coordinate denote time and
d minus one remaining coordinates
denote space uh let l be a rectangular
loop with side lengths r and t where the
sides of length t are parallel to the
time axis so this side t
is going up so you imagine like that and
and then you have
r which is the width okay
so we wish to show that the wilson loop
expectation is bounded by c1 times e to
the minus c2 times r
times t okay for this loop as you
multiply the matrices along the edges of
the loop
okay so it's not very difficult to prove
the perimeter
upper bound that is bounded by c1 times
e to the minus c2 times r plus t
so combined with this information it
suffice suffices to prove
that um it's a small argument suffice it
to prove that instead of this
bound uh the areola bound you can prove
this you know so you
you have something a little bit worse
looking there's a positive c2 times r
plus t
in front of the minus c3 times rt but
you know this is this is fine if you
prove this then
ah then together with the perimeter law
upper bound the
this result will follow
so you have this loop l and you have
this edges going along
l and if this matrices omega e each is a
unitary matrix attached to these edges
and then you apply this pi which is the
representation
which gives you again unity matrices so
pi omega e are unitary matrices attached
to edges
and let so you what you do is you take
one element from each matrix
okay just some arbitrary element one
element from each matrix and take the
product of these elements
let f be the product so we'll call such
a variable a component variable for
l so this wilson the variable
uh wilson variable wl is the trace of
the product of these matrices
so so therefore uh it's a sum of
a large number of component variables
the number is some constant to the power
r plus t
m is the dimension which is fixed so
some constant times r plus to the power
r plus t of these component variables
so it suffices to prove that any
component variable satisfies this bound
because then we just have to multiply
it by some something raised raised to
the power r plus t
and that's that's fine so you can reduce
it this kind of
non-abelian matrix product you know you
can reduce it just to products of
scalars
no problem okay
so so now what you do is you partition
space time into slabs of thickness l in
the time direction so this is the time
direction
so you have slabs of thickness l
so here's a picture um
so let r be the it'd be t over l
that's the number of slabs r is the
number of slabs
uh so then so here is your loop the
thickened line is the loop
okay with our height t
a component variable where you take one
element from each matrix
and you multiply multiply those together
can be written as follows so there is a
component that comes from the bottom
line here which you call u there is
something that comes from the top which
you call v
you don't worry about those and there
are things that come from the sides the
contributions that come from the sides
f1 f2 f3 f4 and then g1 g2 g3 g4
these are the components and so the
total overall the variable is a product
of all of these things so these are the
total components coming from these
parts
is that clear
okay so now let omega be a random
configuration from this lattice gauge
theory
let mu prime be the conditional
probability given the configuration for
all you that belong to the boundary
between slabs so what i am doing
here i condition on the boundaries
between the slabs
okay so once you condition
uh let angle f prime denote the expected
value of f under this conditional
probability so that the overall
expectation
is the expectation of this conditional
expectation so it suffices to prove the
area
for this conditional expectation instead
so under this conditional measure the
nice thing is that the omegas in the
slabs
inside one slab or independent of omega
is inside another slab so this is the
gibbs property of the of lattice gauge
theory it becomes
the slabs become independent once you
condition on the boundaries
so you get this identity that f prime
the conditional expectation is u times v
so u n v
just going back you and v are in the
slabs
in the boundaries so they become
constants one z conditions so
and then you have f 1 g 1 prime f 2 g 2
prime and so on
so so f 1 and g 1 are not independent
see f1 and g1
are not independent but they're
independent of f2 and g2 okay
so so when you have this product you
have this
this identity okay so
so to show that this is bounded by this
it suffices to show that
each of these little components f1 times
g1 prime is bounded by e to the minus
r because then we'll be taking the
product of these things
and the number of slabs is a multiple of
t and so if l is a fixed to it so
it's very important we'll take l to be
fixed with slab so it's not going to
infinity as t and r go to infinity so
so we have a fixed weight slab so
therefore uh if we
can prove this kind of a bound then then
we are done so this is what we want to
show that is the contribution coming
from
the right half and the left half within
a slab if you multiply them
the expectation is decaying uh you know
like e to the minus r the distance
between them
okay
all right
any questions till now
okay so you have this so now here is the
non-trivial center
um so what happens is that because of
the non-feel center
yeah james oh in the like at least i
mean and uh
so what you've traded here i mean you
have this local exponential decay
condition on for edges
and now this is an exponential k uh
exponential decay for not for edges but
for these
uh squares bounding two sides which are
i guess have one of the dimensions it's
constant and you know
basically you've removed one dimension
and you're just and you're trying to
prove
just exponential decay yeah yeah
yeah so so the idea that will come later
on is that the exponential decay
in the full model will imply
exponentially in a thick enough slab
so you can you can take a thick slab you
know if l is large enough larger than
some constant
you can still have exponential decay
within the slab so that that's the main
part of the proof
so now assuming that suppose you can
prove that
then what happens is that the
non-trivial center forces this thing
even after conditioning the expectations
of these conditional expectations of
these fis and gi's will be zero
so this does not hold if you don't have
a non-trivial center the non-trivial
center
together with the structure of lattice
gauge theory ensures that even after
conditioning on the top and bottom
boundaries of a slab you have that
contributions from the two strands of
the
loop that goes in uh they have
expectation zero
so so to prove so we can replace this f
i g
i prime by this truncated correlation
okay so so so once you have the
truncated correlation uh decays
exponentially within the slab
and you have non-trivial center which
ensures this irrespective of the
conditioning
then then it it works out so so this
will follow if you can show correlations
exponentially within each slab for any
given boundary condition on the slab
okay so the key idea is to hold show
that this holds at the thickness of the
slab
is chosen to be sufficiently large okay
so how do we show this
so you take a large but finite slab
minus
n n n is fixed and think of m as very
big
times m minus m to the d minus one
the set of all boundary edges that do
not belong to either the top or the
bottom face will be called the special
boundary so that's a small boundary
that's
surrounding the slab so consider lattice
gauge some given boundary condition
we'll show that the influence of the
special boundary near the center
is exponentially small in m if n is
fixed and i'm going to infinity so
so that that will suffice so if you take
a large slab
and look at something right in the
center it's not very much influenced by
what's on the boundary
i mean no i'm not talking the top and
bottom boundaries i'm talking about the
uh the special boundary so that's a
small boundary that's far away
okay so this is what we want to show
so we will show that um this
if the the slab is sufficiently thick
then this this holds
so take two boundary conditions that
differ only on the special boundary so
take two different boundary conditions
which are the same on the top and bottom
boundaries but differ only in the
special boundary
let mu and mu prime be the probability
measures defined by these two boundary
conditions
a coupling of mu and mu prime is a pair
of random configurations so that omega
comes from mu and omega prime comes from
u prime
uh so what we want to do is to construct
a coupling
so that for any edge near the center of
the slab
omega is equal to omega prime with very
high probability the chance that omega
is not equal to omega e prime is
exponentially small in the distance
so the such a coupling is constructed in
three steps
so first um we construct such a coupling
similar properties in a cube instead of
the slab so just take a cube and do that
and this is where the strong mass gap
condition hole
helps us so using the strong mass step
condition and the coupling
characterization of total variation
distance
we can construct this measure and for
this we need the connectedness of the
gauge group so
so we somehow need to replace each
boundary condition by
each boundary value by a different value
and you know we have to interpolate
smoothly and so on and so there are
there is some work in this
but with the strong mass gap mass gap
condition we can do it in the cube
instead of a slab okay so then what do
we do
we do this so the cube what we do is
show that if you have two different
boundary conditions
then you can couple the measures inside
so that towards the center uh you know
um things are nicely coupled so okay
so then what you do is given any
coupling on the slab we update the
coupling to get a better coupling
so what we do is you you have this slab
large slab
we choose a cube inside it okay
uniformly at random
and then what you do is given this
original coupling
we we fix this a realization of this
pair outside this cube and inside we
generate from
the coupling that we have for the cube
okay so we improve it inside a randomly
chosen cube
and then so then what we show is that
the resulting coupling is a slight
improvement of the original one we get
get some inequality
showing that the result decoupling is a
slight improvement of the original one
and then we do it infinitely mean time
so we choose the cube we
improve it then choose another cube
improve it and you keep on doing that
and and then we can get subsequent limit
of this thing and obtain a coupling um
and there
you know this improvement will will give
some inequality for the limit coupling
that you get
subsequential limit and that will have a
parameter
which will be less than one if the
thickness of the slab is large enough
and that will imply that exponential
decay holds you can you have found a
coupling for which exponential k hold so
that
you know this is how uh you know this
exponential decay in a cube
can be translated to exponential decay
in a in a slab
uh using this repeated improvements
okay uh so this the conditional
thickness has to be large is required to
ensure that certain parameter in this
inequality that we obtain is strictly
less than one which leads to exponential
decay
okay so that's about it and here is the
paper uh it's on
on archive and uh you know i'll be
happy to answer questions thank you
yeah thanks for a great talk um
please if anybody has questions do ask
um
okay so there is a i see a chat message
or something but i cannot see that
the question is uh uh anna thomas asks
could you summarize the other proposed
explanations for quark confinement
and why they are unsatisfactory yeah so
the other proposed
things are all all from physics and um
you know there's
there is this thing with uh truth loops
and poliakov loops and
the physical explanations and of course
they're completely non-rigorous from a
mathematical point of view so for
mathematicians they are
certainly unsatisfactory because they're
not rigorous
but for phases you know i i don't really
know i mean
so so what's the standard of uh
proof or an uh you know theoretical
argument that's accepted it's not
completely clear to me but
but you know they say that it's still
not
still not understood why this happens uh
you know one
possible reason is that you know a lot
of things that
underlie the you know these arguments is
uh
is this renovation group
idea and renovation group as they do it
is a perturbative thing
and perturbation theory is supposed to
not be
effective for um for for this area law
kind of thing and
uh so so it's kind of out of the reach
of uh perturbation theory and that
that's the main
stumbling block i think them because
they don't have a good alternative to
perturbation theory and perturbation
theory cannot catch this
yeah so that's sort of the but you know
i there is some more
about uh the uh the
physics arguments uh you know pollock of
loops and all that in in the paper in
the preprint i have
a little bit more about that yeah so i
see prasad
here so i mean you know if i was going
to compare this to something
the argument seems kind of like a you
know a path coupling argument
where you start with some uh local
correlation condition everywhere and
then you use this to
construct you know to get mixing by
constructing a coupling
yeah is there any it has it has these
components you know uh
various components so the first thing is
this uh
this relation that uh you know the area
law comes because of this that once you
have a non-trivial center
uh you can partition the space into
slabs and within even within each slab
you can
you can get this zero expectations even
after conditioning because of the
non-trivial center condition and and
then you know
then you can and then it's you know it
becomes clear that
once you realize that it becomes clear
that you have to prove some kind of
exponential decay and
within a slab and then you know then you
just go ahead and prove that
and you know so
another question yeah great talk by the
way i didn't
i knew nothing about this topic and uh
you know it
made sense so thank you um i actually
have a
question more about the physics in a
sense or mathematical way of uh
approaching this so is uh
area law pretty much the only rigorous
way is need to get at confinement or
could there be another way right so you
kind of explain
yeah so there are there are some other
there are some other approaches uh but
in some sense they're all sort of
similar to area law you know
so so there is this approach using
police of loops as i said you know
it also gives an explanation for the
area
but it's it's similar so so essentially
you have to at the end of the day you
have to show that
the potential between two quarks uh
is well even if even if not linear at
least it's growing so that
they cannot separate beyond a certain
distance if the potential energy grows
as the as they
separate further and further then by
conservation of energy they cannot
separate more than a certain amount okay
so that's
that's what you have to essentially show
that vr grows vr cannot be constant
and so then this very basic quantum
field theory calculations
show that what wilson showed that um
you know that if you have a rectangle
the winston
uh loop area so somehow
you you kind of always return to that um
but you know there are there are some
some other approaches and there are
these things called in order parameters
that they have
uh which you know uh indicate but uh
i think i think it's basically all
equivalent to the wilson loop
formulations
even the other other approaches they
have at least the argument you gave
would suggest that actually any any
super perimeter law
should give you confinement right that
you didn't you wouldn't need the area
just
yeah you wouldn't even need the area you
wouldn't need the area although you know
you have to be careful because when you
say
confinement people usually take it to
mean that it's a linear growth of
potential you know in the phases often
say that but but you know to be very
precise you
uh you don't really need to need it to
grow linearly just any kind of growth
would be
would be sufficient yeah
yeah anything anything but better than a
perimeter yeah
yeah i may ask one more question sure
this may be more philosophical i don't
know but so
i think you i might have missed why
it's growing like the area rather than
perimeter which
certainly you know james and some of us
who work on slow mixing etc are used to
like usually when it's slow it's low and
the order is like the area
sorry the perimeter or the surface area
yeah so that that was that was the main
insight from this proof
uh which is that uh you know you have
this big loop
and and then you multiply this matrix
along this loop
and then what you do is a condition on
this boundaries between slabs you you
you have the slats and this loop is
going through the slabs two strands of
the loop
and you and you separate your partition
out and then you have this
so let me let me get back to this to
this picture here
here so so you you partition them and
then
what happens is that due to the
non-triviality of the center and
the nature of lattice gauge theory what
you have that this conditional
expectations
also become zero so if you so f i and gi
are the product of group elements from
the loop so so so you see so
if you multiply the group you know the
elements from the matrix along let's say
over here this f3 here
okay in general you wouldn't expect it
to have a
expectation zero conditional expectation
if you condition the boundaries
but the nature of lattice gauge theory
ensures that that is true if the great
gage group is non-trivial center is
non-trivial then then that expectation
is exactly zero which means that as soon
as you can prove
that there is a decay of correlations
within a slab
it's like e to the minus c r then this
these
these things will be also e to the minus
c r and then you multiply sort of t
of them so you get e to the minus c r
times t
okay so so that's that's the somehow
it's very special to lattice gauge
theory and i'm sure
you can formulate a more general class
of models for which this is true
uh and that would be very interesting i
think you know just from a problem
point of view that if you if you have a
general class of models where
this area law can be expected and can be
proved that would be really nice because
you know there's already this uh you
know as i mentioned this type a toy
model of uh
that was studied by
here as an unchaste frolic and russo but
there may be a much nicer you know
larger class of toy models uh
which are not quite lattice gauge
theories but which exhibit these basic
features of area law and all that so
that that would be really
interesting thank
you yeah okay thanks again for a great
talk thanks to all the speakers today
see some of you tomorrow
okay so see you guys nice to see all of
you
yeah good to see you soon yeah good to
see you yes